you've already spent a lot of your
mathematical lives talking about
functions the basic idea is give a valid
input into a function so a member of
that functions domain and then the
function is going to tell you for that
input what is going to be the
corresponding output and we call that
corresponding output f of X so for
example there's many ways of defining
functions you could say something like f
of X is equal to x squared so that means
that whatever X whatever you input into
the function the output is going to be
that input squared you could have
something defined like this f of X is
equal to x squared if if X odd and you
could say it's equal to X to the third
otherwise other wise so if it's an odd
integer
it's an odd integer you square it but
otherwise for any other real number you
take it to the third power this is a
valid way of defining a function what
we're going to do in this video is
explore a new way or potentially new way
for you of defining a function and
that's by using a definite integral but
it's the same general idea so what we
have graphed here this is the T axis
this is the y axis and we have the graph
of the function f or you could view this
as the graph of y is equal to f of T now
what I want and this is another way of
representing what outputs you might get
for a given input here if T is one f of
T is five if T is four F of T is three
but I'm now going to define a new
function based on a definite integral of
f of T let's define our new function
let's say G let's call it G of X let's
make it equal to the definite integral
from negative two to X of F of T DT now
pause this video to really take a look
at it this might look really fancy but
what's happening here is given an input
X G of X is going to be based on
what the definite integral here would be
for that X and so we can set up a little
table here to think about some potential
values so let's say X and let's say G of
X right over here so if X is 1 what is G
of X going to be equal to all right so G
of 1 is going to be equal to the
definite integral going from negative 2
now X is going to be equal to 1 in this
situation that's what we're inputting
into the function so 1 is our upper
bound of F of T DT and what is that
equal to well that's going to be the
area under the curve and above the T
axis between T equals negative 2 and T
is equal to 1 so it's going to be this
area here and week since it's on a grid
we can actually figure this out we can
actually break this up into two sections
this rectangular section is three wide
and five high so it has an area of 15
square units and this little triangular
section up here is too wide and one high
two times one times one half area of a
triangle this is going to be another one
so that area is going to be equal to 16
what if X is equal to 2 what is G of 2
going to be equal to pause this video
and try to figure that out well G of 2
is going to be equal to the definite
integral from negative 2 and now our
upper bound is going to be our input
into the function to 2 of F of T DT so
that's going to be going from here all
the way now to here and so it's the area
we just calculated it's all of this
stuff which we figured out with 16
square units plus another 1 2 3 4 5
square units so 16 plus 5 this is going
to be equal to 21 so hopefully that
helps and the key thing to appreciate
here is that we can define valid
functions by using definite integrals